Sweden wants to join NATO as soon as
possible the Nordic country applied for
membership at the same time as Finland
last year shortly after Russia launched
his full-scale invasion of Ukraine while
Finland was accepted this April turkey
and Hungary are blocking Sweden from
joining let's look at what's holding up
the process and what Sweden can bring to
the Western military Alliance
Sweden is strategically located next to
NATO's newest member Finland
if Sweden joined NATO troops would be
able to go through Swedish territory
into Finland to defend the 800 mile long
border with Russia those two countries
along with Norway and Denmark form a
type of Nordic Fortress in northern
Europe which helps NATO sure obvious
defenses against Russia both over land
but also at Sea in the Baltic Sea
the Baltic Sea is the shortest direct
Waterway from Russia to the West this is
where Sweden Scotland Island is located
NATO often conducts military exercises
here and the island could be used as a
base to protect its Naval forces in
northern Europe by joining NATO Sweden
also reinforces the alliance with
Weaponry it has a surface-to-air
missiles which will help NATO bolsterers
defenses air defenses in this region in
addition Sweden also has submarines for
the Baltic Sea and have a deep knowledge
of Russian Affairs having been so
closely located to Russia for over
decades in a way that many European
countries haven't
for centuries Sweden avoided taking part
in military conflicts but the country
has worked closely with the alliance in
the past Sweden had a close partnership
with NATO for several decades going back
to the mid-1990s where Sweden was part
of the NATO mission in Bosnia
Herzegovina and then since then it has
participated in various NATO missions in
Afghanistan and it's been part of of
what's called an enhanced opportunity
partnership but Russia's invasion of
Ukraine in February 2022 made Sweden
rethink its policy of non-alignment
Russia opposes NATO membership for
Sweden and Finland and said this would
have consequences Swedish and Finnish
intelligence services are prepared for
increased cyber attacks increased
Espionage they say they're not concerned
about direct military action at the
moment but Russia has threatened both
countries there would be consequences of
the joint NATO
every NATO member needs to approve
Sweden's application to join Hungary and
turkey are against it hungary's
Parliament says it's because of what it
calls unwarranted Swedish criticism of
its Democratic record while turkey
accuses Sweden of Sheltering Kurdish
militants that Ankara considers to be
terrorists Sweden made a number of
concessions to Turkey to address these
concerns including passing a new
anti-terrorism law in Parliament they
made it illegal to be a member of a
terrorism organization and that includes
the pkk which is a Turkish militant
group there's Sweden also labels as a
terrorist organization
hundreds of people protested in
Stockholm against the new law saying the
Swedish government is bowing to Turkish
pressure
Turkish presidents retro type erdogan
asked Sweden to stop the protests before
he can agree to the membership
NATO's Secretary General called a
meeting with Sweden and turkey to try
and sort out the issues before the
alliance halted summers in Lithuania in
July
foreign